[Music]
this head impact is well above anywhere
that would start playing this music
unless this is the way it's designed to
be started which seems unnecessarily
painful you had at least five seconds
while this dude's metal hand was
sparking on the asphalt to get this gun
and start doing some damage while were
you waiting for that Charlie has a
robotic arm that this kind of strength
why was this ever even if I harbor
I guess drift mode is cool and all but
why did these are the three cars let it
happen I thought it might be because
they wanted him to escape because they
knew the Trojan arm was already in there
except later they unload a car top easy
on the guy simply pulling forward would
have been so much easier the Kings ban
the Furious not that they'd have much
chance against all this weaponry but are
the London cops too busy looking for
Banksy to do something about this okay
fine that's awesome
yeah but what if there were four guards
that Merlin and eggsy forgot about this
cyborg arm it's bad enough but this
thing can move on its own why didn't it
just strangle eggsy when it had the
chance that's it
this metal arm has everything it needs
to plug an open port and download all
the Kingsmen info ever that's the case
what a stupid way to go about getting it
all you need is the arm in the car right
you don't even need to wait for eggsy to
let you in just break the windshield
take out the driver and be done with it
no worries eggsy just leave that man
hole open when some poor child falls to
their death we will forgive you I mean
your fancy suit smelled bad and stuff
but how could you be bothered this just
backs up my philosophy that
relationships that start with anal sex
are for life this is what eggsy decided
was important enough to jump into a
sewer to attend like what made sense if
it was he and his girlfriend's
anniversary or something but birthday
party last time yeah I was rectum that's
because you're a lightweight sorry to
mellow this bro of love but that wasn't
really not funny I haven't seen someone
overreact this much since Jamie Foxx
turned electric blue because spider-man
forgot his name parents for the first
time tomorrow no tomorrow night would
have been a much better reason to jump
into the sewer than this one also why
are you worried about drinking tonight
when you're visiting her parents
tomorrow night while I enjoy the super
over-the-top villains lair I've got to
wonder how do you build a place like
this without it ever showing up in a
satellite photo I just think it's really
important for new recruits to understand
the history of the Golden Circle roll
joints okay okay fine
movie admits reasons because it wants to
do some meat grinder but even so
how does this work the guy who brought
in the new recruit is untrustworthy
enough to kill but the guy he brought it
into somehow okay seems like that should
be fruit of the poison tree or patty of
the poisoned beef or something no people
who are running away in a panic don't
stop and do a slow burn to see what
might be coming after them scared people
like my nostrils after eating Nashville
hot chicken they never stop running not
that I'm complaining because honestly
this bestie burger is already a bit
gross for my taste but if a live human
went into this mincer it would not only
be kicking out meat be kicking out
clothes and hair and look I still don't
know how these Holograms are sitting in
the correct places at the table they are
not physically out but as we've seen
time again these movies are dicks when
it comes to explaining hologram
societies we saved the world and wasn't
the world completely change by most of
the wealthy elite getting their heads
blown off and all of those million
people who died did the world snap back
to its original self in a year when you
electrocuted him you damaged his implant
instead of his head exploding he only
lost an arm and his vocal cords somehow
this one-armed man was able to escape
valentine's secret lair in the mountains
after everyone had left and weren't all
planes and some underground bunker that
would be impossible to fly planes out of
without codes and air-traffic
controllers also Wow good thing all the
major armed arteries are in the left arm
or old Charlie borer here might have
bled out cannabis Queen casually coerced
his coworker cannibalism and the
Bluetooth logo is his initials really
you pulled up an animation of the
initials coming together to form a logo
and left up previous windows and times
with information you use several courses
ago what a little tab mate let's kill
you sure you need fingerprint
authentication to even open a car door
but this menagerie of death opens with a
random swipe Thanks oh come on you mean
he can just put on these spy glasses and
suddenly get tapped into X's feed
without a password or retinal scan or
other Kingsman knowing about it
what are we supposed to think eggsy
Sawyer certainly that level of firepower
just completely shut down the feet which
likely means he just saw the screen go
dark and really shouldn't be all that
concerned also this is a point that
movie tries to have both ways when just
a few seconds later these guys are none
the wiser as each of them is taken out
if your missile warning system goes off
a split-second before you explode you
went with the wrong missile warning
system company considering this bowling
alley is high tech enough to have
automated scoring why are these pins
just sitting here not being reset is she
waiting for Elton John to reset them
we're buzzed spins slide turn are we
impressed yet points for strength but
shouldn't they be a tad bit concerned
about accuracy I'm only alive because my
address wasn't on the theater base with
the agents and why are the addresses of
the agents on that database anyway even
if secret organizations do store
addresses this way would they make those
accessible from a computer inside a taxi
that sounds like something you'd have to
mission impossible to get also this
means poppy decided to coordinate an
attack on all these agents houses and
basically hoped they'd all be hung
luckily nearly all in work and too bad
she didn't have a disgruntled statesman
in her corner because she didn't know
about a whole other secret
crime-fighting group that could stop her
well from Kingsman I'd like to buy some
wine and he's tasting room number three
please so everything was on that
database except the King's man's
Doomsday Protocol location I mean sure
you don't want to put anything sensitive
on the database that the bad guys might
use against you so good call there
remember this forget I did quick
treating the audience like they are uber
fans of the first movie so too much to
ask for a sequel that can be enjoyed on
its own what's with hiding this clue it
was in a safe behind a magic pendant
opening door just leave a note with a
phone number ten times out of ten if
someone is drunk enough whiskey to see
this they would be too drunk to find it
or even comprehend what they are looking
at in case you confused it with Kentucky
I rang is this a standard-issue spy
watch that both agencies use even though
they are not even aware of each other
how the hell do they know how to use it
then you mean tequila was going to kill
Harry before they figured how their
story was true and even if he wasn't
gonna do it why would cap when we walk
in and yell stop like she was saving his
life yes you remember the place where
Harry was killed in the last movie it
was Kentucky of course the place where a
secret American spy outfit exactly like
the Kingsmen just so happens to be oh so
this is some next-level Kentucky Bulls
about to happen here first I'm getting a
crazy spike of extreme low-frequency
waves extreme low-frequency waves what
does that even mean why are you
monitoring for them and why is their
presence an emergency that demands an
immediate escort second your helicopters
tap
the land immediately after Valentine
walks away and they don't even see you
and finally we developed our alpha gel
technology for our own agents in the
event of a head shot the gel protects
the brain protect the brain you mean
what's left of the brain right the
problem isn't that the brain needs
protecting the problem is that the brain
is currently located outside of its
original container we use men nights
microbots to repair tissue damage and it
repairs tissue damage how does it
contain prometheus
this is simply the cure for death itself
right why isn't someone in this movie
made a trillion dollars selling this
technology and that will have no
consequences whatsoever
can't he just be on time what does it
fucking matter stop with your late
bullshit in movies assholes until you
get rid of the perimeter landmines okey
wearing a suit thank you very much
how exactly was that best supposed to
protect him from a landmine was he
crawling another wide view and flyover
of the compound this movie could have
been under two hours if it cut back on
the grandiose landscape porn if I wanted
to fly over the countryside I'd go to
Disney and ride Sora oh Jesus Christ
this movie is starting to feel like a
Bob Hope Christmas special also Jeff
Bridges if you count Sir Elton that's
five Oscar winners in this movie as I
learned watching Sesame Street sometimes
the best place to find Oscars is
slumming in the trash also also a place
that holds whiskey and high regard would
never use the codename champagne jog on
you hoser we need to recreate a shock or
trauma from his past to trigger his
memory what you mean you don't have a
special gel or microchip or Criterion
Collection DVD of the King's Speech that
will help trigger his memory we got to
waste time with this movie that's nearly
two and a half hours and yeah we'd send
the fact that something so easy would
fix his memory but we'd be nice about it
these art supplies are unmoved as am i
well if you save the world you know what
that means
man X I should really look into getting
an anal sex rewards cart with enough
points he could get a free popcorn you
know girl go everything was supposed to
be bigger in America goes on your finger
the surveillance trackers in the tip and
we had no choice but to make it look
like a condom for some easy jokes the
hand is not a Lucas membrane exit really
moving the only way this incredibly
advanced spy agency can track someone is
with the finger condom that has to be
gynecological inserted what if she's not
into you what if you needed to track a
man leave he has less defined sense of
decency and maturity than a Logan Paul
video puppy would you post you should
the police okay but it's really bad for
you that's why I keep whole bowls of
sugar here despite the rent that I'm
about to go on about it
get me started on tobacco and alcohol I
peddle that stuff you're in the fortune
500 wait is this movie for recreational
drug use or against it why is the
villain making so much sense do not
break the rules which is why I have
invested in robots because they are so
much more reliable and trustworthy than
human beings but yet I still kept human
employees around for some reason and
what's the deal with this angel
character anyway the movie made it seem
like he'd be important in some way and
now he's already being fed to the
mechanical dogs you know I'm busting for
a PhD you can deal with me if you want
this is the kind of sexy and disgusting
that I expect from the steel dossier not
over-the-top spy movies tents at
festivals no matter how opulent do not
have indoor plumbing this means she's
part of the Golden Circle right why does
she get to hang out at a music festival
during a time when her boss is about to
unleash her big plan and by the way this
is exactly why you don't mark your
henchmen with easily identifiable
markings first pov ever
so it's 849 p.m. in Sweden right now
which is six hours ahead of Louisville
but Kentucky must be going through one
of their trademark polar nights right
now because that would mean it's 249
p.m. there what did he find a 24-hour
pet store in rural Kentucky forgetting
the fact at the time is anyway it's
nearly nighttime and harry is still
sleeping when he brings this dog in this
goes on for some time you look like some
looking for a knife there's no sign loud
enough to express my irritation with
this bull sure we need another Harry
teaches an asshole a lesson and a bar
scene so that we can see that he's back
but does it have to be the most rootin
tootin a stereotypical redneck face
imaginable also this brings up another
point you never talk about your spine
and a bar especially a bar with so many
dickheads in it
this is actually a pretty clever play
off the scene in the original but like
almost everything else in this movie it
depends on your memory of the first
movie for it to even work this is a
90-minute movie bloated to almost two
and a half hours by a severe case of
sequelitis swelling Manas maketh man let
me translate that for you thank God
native Kentuckian Pedro Pascal saves the
day for the southern stereotypes in this
movie
oh wait as cool is a retractable whip
might seem exactly what vortex is that
whip disappearing into like most
megalomaniacal villains poppy somehow
has control over the American airwaves
to override every channel Joker style to
deliver this message some of you are
already infected this is exactly like
the Tim Burton Joker plan just switch
cosmetics with drugs and it's the same
thing breathing becomes impossible
luckily poppy had this perfectly timed
to the second to prove her point
I guess that's funny because it's Elton
John saying it well the shocker bruce
greenwood is playing the president again
my guess is that this is either leftover
footage from 13 days or from national
treasure 2 easiest paycheck ever Fox
News isn't comparing poppy Adams to
Hillary Clinton in this scene step up
five three four madness what I'm
proposing is we appear to agree to her
demands to prevent global panic and then
let the junkie scum go down in flames
good god what a psychopath I know that's
the point it's a cartoon president
making a cartoon decision but even a
psychopathic president would know that
letting all these people die wouldn't
end the war on drugs still absolutely no
one brings up this point in the movie
and that's a shame we're not talking
about a handful of hostages we could be
looking at the deaths of hundreds of
millions worldwide you know like a year
ago and that same thing happened and
everybody forgot about it
who are you I'm here to collect this
antidote was this how the lab was going
to give representatives of their
countries the antidote that this works
for even the briefest moment is worthy
of a sin and the fact that poppy has
drones that are going to deliver the
antidote anyway is worthy of another
yes Harry's butterfly effect distracts
him but did he lose total awareness why
isn't he answering them though how are
you why did they even need Harry on this
mission and why do they need him to do
this when Halle Berry can close the labs
cooking doors remotely so he gains full
control of the lift and instead of just
bringing them back up to the top he just
spins them really fast
why it's magic lasso has an electric
slicing setting apparently what else
gonna do if aquaman sits on it will he
admit that he's afraid to dying
also what exactly is the plan here to
cut a hole that somehow lets the whip
out enough to reach all the way up and
cut the tension lines so that the
machine can plummet into a ravine how
exactly is this helping what the since
when are they wearing parachutes and why
I swear to god this movie has conjured
up more magically appearing items than
JK Rowling this gun-slinging is actually
pretty damn creative and fun but there's
no possible way one of these Golden
Circle Jerks hasn't had time to reload
their automatic weapon and take this
lone gunman out for good in these
Gatling guns seriously not penetrate the
stone wall that Harry and eggsy are
taking cover behind these things are
super powerful right come on Moony
another magic out at this point we can
just call this X Mach another movie and
be done with it
first I've got to find a way to get back
up to that lab and retrieve more
antidote your super secret rendezvous
point was within eyesight of the lab but
wonder they found you in fact here's an
extra sin for their not finding you
sooner if you ever wanted to do more
than this
look H beat you're the one that took the
part and I assume they sent you the
script so this one's on you emailing
from poppy from a senior partner at the
firm they're coordinates yeah to the
facility in Italy not her secret hideout
it says it plain as day in the email why
would she arrange pick up at her
headquarters or send the coordinates
there ever I know the president decided
not to cave to Poppy's demands but did
he really commissioned the production of
all these cages or was there a caged
warehouse somewhere that finally got his
big break princess of Sweden who I might
remind you as a princess is somehow in
level 2 of the poison drug state without
someone rushing her to a hospital
poppy you expecting a lawyer - poppy
somehow didn't tell her gun-toting
henchmen that her lawyer was going to
show up tonight dogged you had one job
minesweeper also I thought land mines
blow up as soon as you step on them and
that they don't move technique we've
been taught movies is a lot but I guess
like bullets in the water and we only
use 10% of our brains this is the troop
that we have to accept except here
luckily I have this little known fact
luckily I have this was actually the
working title of this movie during
production
country row
I don't know how this can be perceived
as anything but a ruse but mooby's got a
movie I guess we're gonna really have to
dine here
we've seen them single-handedly take out
more goons than this before and in about
two minutes they will take out five
times this many why not just have Merlin
hold tight take out the guards and puppy
then deactivate the landline it would
literally be the least ridiculous thing
in the entire movie also don't worry in
the next sequel some other country will
be nearby monitoring low-level
frequencies might just happen to have
some mind reassimilation buddy so really
totes NBD once again henchmen decide not
to go for the legs after it's clear that
shooting the umbrella is not going to
work
wait a minute did the guy behind Harry
make a noise so loud in the middle of
the gunfire that Harry was able to turn
around and kill that guy before he got
the chance to kill him does anybody know
how to kill people before they're
detected anymore
by hell you've already seen this
briefcase be a rocket launcher and a
machine gun but now there's nothing
inside it even if I had an entire
suspension bridge it's believed it
wouldn't be enough I guess this is funny
I know sometimes the dark recesses of my
heart won't allow it
but this is a 70 year old recording
artist pulling off a martial arts move
and my brain can't handle that either
also a movie uses Elton John to break
the fourth wall and I can't even muster
any anger because it also broke my
spirit at least an hour ago
Harry shoots a thing that somehow works
luckily all bombs come in threes in this
world and this umbrella has an unlimited
supply of usefulness stocked inside it
you already broke that wall Elton there
are no walls left to break can we all
just go home now
we've already seen a dog operate at 76%
so why wouldn't he be able to come out
and play at 89%
which gives way first the human sternum
or a stone column wrong answer movie
knowing what we know about this
mechanical arm ex's chest should be a
crater right now he survives this all of
this like the whole movie mechanical
Dogma necessary rather than simply
killing him which is what they've been
doing the whole movie up until now LX
Jonica this has been possible the whole
time the whole time sure give her a
reason to take off the Elton John
failsafe you dick so my mate Brandon for
Roxy for JB formerly well awesome I'll
be alive if we ever decide to make
another sequel so oh god damn it I mean
I didn't forget about whiskey or
anything I was just hoping the movie did
and these are trained agents who
conveniently forget the agent for plot
sake you try anything funny or not
turning this thing electric so why don't
you already I'm just gonna spend the
next several minutes monologuing about
your very thin and very convenient
motives for wanting drug users dead none
of which is necessary since you easily
could have killed them both by now and
just let the infected druggies down I
think he sounds like a bright idea this
badass gun sling and lasso twirling
killer is essentially stopped by a very
bright light this is some now you see me
two bulls right here the president
actively sanctioned the deaths of
hundreds of millions of people there is
no way even with impeachment that they
would put handcuffs around the President
of the United States in the White House
it's even doubtful that the president
would be arrested or have to go through
any legal proceedings and there would be
a great debate as to whether his
decision was even illegal
strange things are afoot and the
circle-k
how is it I know what people taste like
[Music]
Soylent Green is made out of people
here's a new dragon fire cannot kill a
dragon
I'm the dude
[Music]
you raped my sister you murdered her you
killed her children how did you take
down Captain America we shot him in the
legs because his shield is the size of a
dinner plate